I was sent some problems by one of the
viewers out there I believe his name is
Cortado or kurta GOI I apologize I'm
sure I'm mispronouncing it but they are
really interesting problems what's
interesting about them is that they
don't involve super fancy mathematics
they just involve an elegant way to
apply fairly simple mathematics so
without me talking too much about the
problems let's try to solve one of them
actually I don't know where I'm gonna
categorize this either in algebra or in
the brainteaser playlist but or maybe
both so an officer on horseback starts
at the back of a column of marching
soldiers and rides to the front of the
column then turns around and rides to
the rear of the column if the rider
travels three times as fast as the
column moves and the column is 100
metres long okay I think we have enough
information to start drawing this so let
me draw the column of soldiers I'll just
draw this as a big fat line so that's
the column of soldiers I'm about to
cough excuse me I've learned not to
cough directly in the microphone don't
wanna blow your speakers out okay so
that's the column of soldiers right
there and we've there we the problem
tells us that it's a hundred metres long
so this distance right here is a hundred
meters and it's moving with some
velocity let's say to the right so I'm
gonna just call it it's moving with some
velocity V we'll have to stay abstract
there cuz it doesn't tell us the
velocity and then we have what is this
the officer is that what they then write
the officer right I never make sure I
was wasn't giving the incorrect title so
an officer on horseback starts at the
back of a column so he starts here he's
on his horse he's on his horse
that's my rendition of the horse for
these purposes as a officer on on the
back and he is going to while this while
the whole column is going forward with
the velocity V he's gonna go to the
front of it obviously can go faster
because he's on a horse and then he's
going to go to the back and they want to
know how far did this whole column move
and how fast is he going let's see if
the Grider travels three times as fast
as the column so if the column is
traveling with the velocity V he's going
to be travelling with the velocity of 3
V so let's think about two things let's
think about the time it takes him to go
to the front of the column and then the
time it takes to go back so let's say t1
is equal to time to front time to front
and then t2 would be time to back time
to back there might be other ways to
solve this but this is the way that's
jumping out into my brain so let's
figure out what the time to the front of
the column is so over some period of
time so how far is the column going to
move over t1 the column is going to move
well let's just actually let me write a
little formula here you'd although you
I'm sure you know this formula distance
is equal to rate times time right so
over time 1 how far does the column move
it's going to move V V times time 1
times time 1 and how far is this guy
going to move well we're saying over
time 1 he moves to the front of the
column so this whole column is moving to
the right and at the same time this guy
is moving to the right faster so at the
end of time 1 which i've defined is the
time it takes him to get to the front
what's true about the officer on the
horseback he will have had to travel a
hundred meters further than the column
right in order to catch up to the front
of the column he would have had to go
100 meters further than the column so
the distance that that the column
travels plus 100 plus 100 meters is
going to be the distance that the
officer travels in the same amount of
time and what's the distance that he
travels in that same amount of time
well distance is equal to rate 3v times
time t1 time to the front so this is a
relationship between velocity and the
time to the front let's see if we can
simplify this a little bit so see if we
subtract V t1 from both sides we get 100
is equal to 3 VT 1 minus VT 1 that's 2
bt1 and divide both sides by two you get
50 v t1 is equal to 50 the velocity of
the of this of this column of soldiers
times the time it takes this officer to
get to the front is equal to 50 well
that doesn't solve our our problem yet
we want to know how far does a column
move we have two variables with one
equation not helpful yet let's see if t2
can help us is a little bit alright I'll
switch colors to ease the monotony okay
time to back so now we're in this
opposite situation where the guy has
gotten here he turns around I'd argue
immediately he turns around immediately
and he goes back with a velocity of 3v
so my question to you is he starts out
here and relative to him he's going this
direction at a velocity of 3 V and the
back of the column is moving towards him
with the velocity of V right so if you
think about it the the back of the
column is going to be approaching the
rider with the velocity of 4 V when you
have two velocities are moving in
opposite directions right if I move if I
give I move in this direction at 60
miles per hour and you're moving in that
direction at 60 miles per hour relative
to me if I assume that I'm stationary
you would look like you're coming at me
at 120 miles per hour so that same idea
this officer is going to be approaching
the end of the column the back of the
column with the velocity of 4 V so how
long does it take him to get to the to
the back well let's see his velocity is
4 V I'll do that in green so his
velocity is 4 V that's how fast he's
approaching the back of the column and
it's gonna take him time to times time 2
and his distance he's gonna travel 100
meters because that's the length of a
column is equal to 100 and let's see if
we divide both sides of this by 4 we get
velocity times time 2 is equal to 25 and
once again we have one equation with two
unknowns it doesn't help us a lot let's
review the problem again to see if if
somehow we can use this information and
this information to solve what they're
asking
four so they want to know how far does
the column let me they want to know how
far does the column move by the time the
officer arrives back at the rear of the
column so they want to know how how far
did this whole thing move over the
entire time of this problem happening
what was the entire time was t1 plus t2
that's the entire time t1 to go to the
front and then t2 to go back to the back
so how far did the column move
well the column distance is equal to
rate times time so the column will move
its distance is equal to the columns
rate velocity and then what's the time
that this whole little problem occurs on
well t1 is how long it takes the officer
to get to the front right plus t2 so
this is what we're solving for this is
what we need to know we you know the
thoth that the distance traveled by the
column and once again we have all these
variables but maybe we can do something
interesting let's look at this so what
is so if we just distribute this we have
distance is equal to V times t1 plus V
times t2 and do we know what these
things are well sure we were able to
kind of kind of stumble our way into the
into what these values are and that's
what's interesting about this problem we
never figured out V we never figured out
t1 or t2 but we can figure out this
whole thing because V times t1 they tell
us is 50 so we can substitute it back
here so the distance is equal to 50 plus
what's V times T - well we solved it
here when we figured out how long it
would take to go back to the front of
the column so that's 25 so that we'll
put over here so the total distance that
the column traveled is 50 plus 25 meters
or 75 meters and this is a neat problem
because they didn't tell us how fast the
column is actually going they're just
saying it's V they just said that the
officer is going 3 times as fast but we
don't know absolute velocities but we
were still able to figure out even
without even knowing the absolute times
we were still able to figure out the
total distance that the column traveled
anyway I hope you enjoyed that and if
you did you can thank Kourt agio for the
problem